el proyecto de ley ya había sido parte
de una discusión dentro del legislativo
en ecuador justo pasó para veto
presidencial antes de que inician las
manifestaciones que duraron 18 días en
el ecuador durante el paro en el
promovido por el movimiento indígena y
claro podríamos decir que regular el uso
legítimo de la fuerza sería redundar a
lo que ya está reconocido a nivel
internacional en la constitución pero
legislativa periodo era una muestra del
querer generar reglas claras para que la
fuerza pública pueda actuar en contra de
la delincuencia y hacer también una
especificación que ya es parte del
principio del uso del legítimo de la
fuerza en cuanto a la excepcionalidad
que tiene que tener está en el contexto
de una movilización ese es el punto que
el ministro del interior ha resaltado
como el que el gobierno no estaría de
acuerdo a lo cual me pregunto qué tiene
de diferente el poder hacer una remarca
dentro del proyecto de ley en cuanto a
la excepcionalidad sobre todo cuando se
busca dar respuesta políticas a
problemas políticos no hace el uso de la
fuerza pública para dar respuesta a
estos problemas políticos está usted
hablando precisamente de las últimas
protestas en el país se podría afirmar
que estas objetivos objeciones por parte
del ejecutivo son consecuencia directa
de las imágenes de represión vistas
durante las mismas
sí creo que vienen a reforzar justamente
eso pero dudo mucho que el legislativo
se línea al pedido del ejecutivo porque
el legislativo perdió fuerza de hecho ya
no tiene mayoría entonces el reafirmar
el uso excepcional que ya es un
principio de el uso legítimo de la
fuerza lo que hace es reconocer que no
se tiene que utilizar la fuerza pública
para entre comillas lanzar la
estabilidad democrática sino que la
fuerza pública debe estar justamente
para su razón de ser que es la seguridad
y la lucha contra el crimen organizado
en nuestro país al respecto creo que
justamente el gobierno no está en la
mejor posición para presentar esto estás
objeciones ante legislativo con la
fuerza que ha perdido y recordemos que
la constitución es muy clara que la
fuerza pública está subordinada al poder
civil y el poder civil es el que
determina justamente el grado la
discrecionalidad con la cual se va a
hacer uso legítimo de esa fuerza depende
mucho de la cadena de mando de jerarquía
repartiendo por ejemplo de estado los
ministros encargados de esfuerzos de más
policías y del institucional como esta
fuerza es utilizada en el contexto de
las movilizaciones se observaron a
través de reportes de los mismos
derechos humanos un uso desmedido de la
fuerza en diferentes contextos en el
cual manifestantes sufrieron agresiones
y muchos de ellos fueron asesinados por
el impacto de perdigones entonces esto
avivado más del debate en el que se
necesitan cambios y reformas
estructurales a los aparatos de policía
para poder realizar su tarea no y
carolina brevemente como ha sido
recibido este proyecto por parte de la
ciudadanía
bueno la ciudadanía en sí ha sido
bastante crítica al respecto porque se
cuestiona cómo es posible que la fuerza
pública actúe de una manera tan
desmedida en un contexto de
movilizaciones y no cumpla de la misma
forma ante hechos de violencia muerte y
asesinatos y sicariato que día a día
pasan un rico país entonces existencia
esa gran incógnita de por qué no se hace
uso de esa misma fuerza en un contexto
de cuidado de protección de la seguridad
de las y los ecuatorianos entonces esa
es la la imagen que la ciudadanía si
llego a partir de las protestas de ahora
depende como decía los temas de fondo
que es la doctrina los reglamentos y los
protocolos que orientan el trabajo de
las fuerzas públicas